do you man like that the money i don't
care part of it people
are taking it and that's why i don't
hate on it because like get yours man so
like
with dylan he could fight in bellator
against some contender in the
welterweight division which he's two and
oh and bellator he could fight in there
maybe make
i bet they pay him 20 and 20 25 so 50
grand or
he can fight jake paul get millions and
millions of eyeballs
and millions and millions of dollars
yeah so like i don't know why you
wouldn't do it
unless for jay and less for dylan it's
like an ego thing
you know what i'm saying where he's like
no i wouldn't be taking serious i was
like dude
fight this dude and then do bellator get
paid get all these uh you get that fan
base then parlay it into something else
oh like yeah yeah
it makes so much sense like looking at
it from a consumer perspective like i
want to watch
crazy wwe stuff yeah like you know what
i mean we're just talking about with
kids and what do they have to watch they
gravitate
to like stuff that's like not like oh
this is bad he's causing trouble i want
to see that
it's a tough road to go i think there's
clearly a lane for him because you look
at how jake paul did against dave robs
like there's
and people are buying it so there's a
lane but you know
i you don't want to see the ufc get
involved like muddy the waters like you
still want the pure
sport yeah but then but i also want them
to do the thing
so i support all of it yeah i think you
got to be careful cross-pollinating the
story leading up to the fight people are
interested in
like you versus big sean because big
sean smashed your girl
i don't know
because you'd want to fight him because
she cheated on you with big sean
people be like oh damn like i want to
see that like did you ever see
uh paulie malanagi and adrian broner it
was so great they fought over a side
piece
yeah oh no i didn't do that yeah and
then in the ring in the ring paul you
get something goes
nobody talks about my side and she's
she's reading she's
and paulie's almost in tears i'll never
forget it nobody touched my side
that's funny like they don't there's
like certain areas of like other sports
you like you can't do that
like you can't just be like i'm going to
go to the nba
you know what i mean like that like you
know like i'm a train you really you
know
really yeah you you're saying as far as
professional
yeah like like the way like these like
these guys are like i'm gonna start
boxing
they start boxing and they go yeah yeah
yeah they can't do that with like the
nba i like they're like you can't do
that in any way i would say though
people
like what you said about how he yelled
that out like no one says that about my
sidekick
but the thing is people are very
sensitive about their side pieces too
that's what people get it's like oh no i
just care about my main girl but no
people have feelings for the side pieces
and there's an ego thing when like your
side you call your side piece and she's
just like
nah i'm good i'm like doing something
else i'm like when did that happen
you were always on call like ready to go
now you're you know and and there's a
little animosity i know my boy who's
like a
big musician dude you know what i'm
saying like he you know he's like a rock
star he has all these girls around all
the time yeah
he got like butt hurt because like his
side feet and like his eyes like oh yeah
my psych piece broke up with me
what'd you do for him that hurt mo yeah
it's
tough but to your point uh chappelle as
far as like uh you can't do any other
sport
it fighting's a little different because
it's not like
i guess they did it with cm punk but
it's like you know it's not
it takes years to be like the level of
like some of these fighters like they
can't just go and be
a ferguson you know they can't just go
out and be a mother but they're not
trying
to fight those guys yeah i mean i get i
guess jake's trying to fight connor
that's what i'm saying like
but in a boxing match but still that's a
little weird but
yeah but still like huh but everybody to
become floyd mayweather
he's not trying to become a floyd
mayweather but like i'm saying it takes
he's just trying to fight him yeah
they're trying to get paid yeah yeah
it's
easy back even for the fighter i mean
for floyd he's probably like this is
easy
well if you think about floyd like you
could fight anybody in the world but you
know logan paul has
a gillian followers on youtube yeah he's
super relevant he's going to bring
eyeballs
yeah yeah it's you know floyd thinks
it's an easy day in the in the office
let's just make some money
so he's like why not how about that when
i get off stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic
song